Ali Wong you gotta get out your youth
claim to be into food get on a burger
caliber show from voicing many of the
angst-ridden characters from his hit
animated series big mouth to his
upcoming stand-up tour middle-aged boy
Nick Kroll is a chameleon in the world
of comedy but he can blend into foodie
circles too thanks to his VIP chef
connects and his niche culinary
references so to celebrate Nick's
comedic genius I'm making a custom
burger tasting menu just for him
featuring a hormone fueled behemoth a
Jewish deli spin-off and the ultimate
foodie fantasy Nick Kroll
welcome to the show Rob thanks man
welcome you're on fire right now
obviously I'm here to promote everything
constantly right but I really just want
to eat these [ __ ] burgers man so
they're perfect you're in store cuz I've
kind of created like a burger a tasting
menu for you all of this based on your
success based on things in your career
right think of it as burger omakase you
know what that means I yeah yeah you're
a true foodie I am a capital F yes I I
do like to eat good food I like to eat
good food prepared by chefs that I trust
and this is a real trust fall for me
what is your favorite salad burger I
don't love too many things on my burger
yes Curtis yeah okay you don't simple
cute yeah yeah I mean we might stretch
those here stretch my but my burger
boundaries
burger number one you've got some
exciting news
bigmouth is back for another season yes
and this burger is gonna be influenced
by that show that's all I've ever wanted
adolescence is about feeding your
impulses this burger is basically
channeling in 13-year old Alvin so your
home your hormone food monster yeah
exactly
we're gonna go with these two patties
right here gorgeous I got this gigantic
spatula in this towel right here whoa oh
this is straight-up porn to me hahaha
we're gonna see it in this guy mmm
that's black pepper that's not dried up
duties right exactly okay great
throwing on the buns here and that's a
that's a sesame bun not as you covered
in big Mario's old classic New York
South great this is a bacon patty that
we made it just ground up bacon all of
my bodily functions amassed and do one
pretty much I love big mouth all the
characters are amazing is a ton of them
the hormone monster that's gotta be your
favorite one all right so like right now
if Maury were here he'd be like grill
that [ __ ] burger and give it to me
Jesus melting so pretty I'm gonna shut
that [ __ ] burger in my mouth
but then there's Rick the hormone
monster
this is Russian dressing
uh-huh then we got the double patty they
doubled up oh you're not skimping on
that big no this is yes did I call a
ranch blasted fries okay you're giving
those fries a facial and to top it off
yeah some reason adolescent olive in
love you know spicy food so we're gonna
throwing on some banana chili there it
is there it is I don't think I have to
explain why it's called the big mouth
burger can I give you a nice transition
in alman I can't wait to wrap my big
[ __ ] mouth around this
goddammit that's so good
how much of your real-life experiences
influence big mouth I mean a ton of my
life is in big mouth like me getting
pantsed when I was 13 in front of my
childhood crush and she saw my bald
little cashew everyone involved in the
show are all people that I've been
friends with for a number of years and
Ali Wong is on the show nice he's gonna
play a pansexual and she done the show
no Ali Wong you gotta help your youth
claim to be in the food get on the
[ __ ] burger she on the burger shop
program - yeah Jewish deli burger you
know we've talked about Russ & Daughters
I'm in selected Jewish deli thing you
grow up upstate so you must be a
connoisseur of like I Jewish deli I do
like I do like me some Jewish deli it's
funny cuz LA actually has a lot of good
Jewish delis so much so that I've made a
song about it called la deli yes
[Music]
pastrami record beat I'm a pastrami guy
more than a corned beef guy right yes
pastrami for me is the undisputed king
of Jewish deli meats yes I think it's
like beef bacon I want to change my name
to beef big let's get started
great throwing this on on here for sure
yeah then we got like the cutest rye
bread in the world
this is pastrami from Katz's the great
Katz's shoutout to Katz's Deli which
brings me to my first question well why
are why are the guys who cooked Jewish
deli Katz is all Dominican close but
you're bicoastal sure right yeah
Langer's or cassis cassis boom let's
build this guys let's do it got the
right bread uh-huh and we're gonna do a
little schmear of thousands mm-hmm
russian dressing sure every you want to
call sure put crumb sauce sauerkraut Oh
pastrami here you're not skimping on the
straw me no you can't holy smokes this
is like a Reuben sub the corned beef
pastrami piled high Burger calling it
the Jewish deli burger that's that's it
oh man please oh if you could shrink me
down to take like a tiny shower in the
bottom of this [ __ ] this like burger
grease for shower what do we think
[ __ ] man I feel like a little bit like
taking a bite and then making my comment
like I'm Guy Fieri but I'll do it as
like Jewish Guy Fieri okay
[Music]
well that's good
little donkey sauce is ready to go so
before we get on to the next I'll have
something special for you okay you ready
for this
mmm it's called jus pretty that's
jeopardy for Jews yes
tests how well you know your roots right
all right category number one guess the
[ __ ] I'm gonna read some celebrity names
which one is a [ __ ] aka not Jewish right
hey Lenny Kravitz uh-huh
be pink uh-huh see Jason Biggs uh-huh
and D Jenny slate Jason Biggs is the non
Jew correct [ __ ] do this all day Lenny
Kravitz the most Jewish Jewish person
though Jason Biggs
yeah I know it's he's taking jobs away
ready for category number two so right
it's called a whole yada Yiddish no huh
ding-ding-ding-ding Daily Double
I'm have a special video okay just for
you okay great
Nick Kroll it's me rabbi Michael Paley
the family rabbi and Mazel Tov for being
on the burger show okay you have known
your family for a long time and I know
that they're in the security business
and you because you're a comedian in the
insecurity business a very always good
to use what you have
I haven't seen you since the bait party
some time ago but I want to know how
much you retain from Hebrew school so I
have a question for you think about
Yiddish words and see if you can spot
the fake one
okay bonus points if you know what each
of them means the first one mish pasa
it's family the second one flat Komaki
plot Komaki I don't know the third one
Gretel uh-huh and the fourth one out the
caca
okay good luck Mazel Tov there it is
you know that guy I do know that guy
he's like he's dear friends of my
parents okay
rabbis are real performers like rabbis
are just like comedians who like
wouldn't go to open mikes
so it's like you go one way if you're
like a Jew wants to perform either you
become a comedian or you go become a
rabbi Wow
it's either/or it's like Filipinos
beginner Cernik not exactly understood
yeah you nailed the first one so yeah
Mishka polka is family and that's rad
cool I don't know what it is and I
believe plot Komaki is the fake one okay
you narrowed it down to the right - yeah
but I was wrong in the era I know yeah
plot Kamaka means gossiper uh-huh and
breath will is way up work they're kind
of you're kind of doing yeah yeah I'm
kind of Jewish can't you ish third
burger this is what I call the 2019
foodie burger gone away are the days of
stupid [ __ ] on burger mm-hmm don't work
caviar
no more truffle now it's all about dry
aged beef mm-hmm you know no douchey
brioches about the perfect seeded but
it's about ratios
I see what you're pitching and I'm way
um yeah dry aged beef is where it's at
you gotta use got assaulted I gotta use
a ton of salt yeah this is one that's
not old man dandruff no this is not
olive and Andrew buoys Oh ooh but
there's a tender touch oh yeah you have
to yeah I like feeling see that sear oh
it's beautiful hey that's a cheddar
sharp cheddar it's boys that's a short
cheddar okay cooties want that next they
want that next level they want a classy
they want a cheddar to like something
pungent uh-huh something like that has
great mouthfeel sure these are all
foodie term
booty turn yeah kind of agree bold with
no greens or not you it's sizzling just
right you feel that bun
yeah the buttons have to be perfect this
is our own special bun that we have here
really that's the usual arguably one of
the best burgers in town that's what
I've heard I think it is yeah we'll put
on our special sauce
you know what I think can suck a dick on
a burger a slice of tomato if it's not
tomato season yeah what the [ __ ] are you
doing putting a tomato on over I
couldn't agree more
it's like oh I want like a cold slippery
mealy nonentity on my burger
what the [ __ ] is that here it is this is
2019 dry aged beef mmm
foodie burger galore and now I'm going
to [ __ ] this is real food porn this
is what foodies [ __ ] do now is it
this is the next stage in foodie is you
can't just eat the food you got to make
love to it give it a look let it know
it's bad oh it's just nothing this
burgers a gusher that's it man like
that's that's what I got for you oh did
you like for the best
that first burger evokes adolescence and
childhood that second burger brings me
back to my Jewish roots and the snare
burger speaks to Who I am now I'm about
quality ingredients and I like to you
know I'm trying to [ __ ] burgers so this
fellow [ __ ] yeah that sounds like sounds
like I nailed it it sounds like you
nailed it yeah I'm glad we got to do
this we take you good luck on the new
season good luck on the [ __ ] comedy
tour yeah thanks man thanks man thanks
for having me
[Music]
you
[Music]
what's up everybody it's having Kyle out
of the burger show make sure you turn on
your notifications smash that like
button smash that subscribe button and
thank you for watching